[Music]  new at 11 a Mainstay in the valley is  back ready to make sure your cocktail is  of perfect proportions Southern Glazer  Wine and Spirits held an open house  tonight showcasing its Academy and what  it has to offer the company has been  around since 2000 but their Academy has  been shut down since the pandemic as  their director of Mixology puts it their  return comes at the perfect time  so just about every bar restaurant  liquor store out there has at least 50  percent of their employees that are new  the old ones were trained and seasoned  and ready to go the new ones still need  to get in with all the mechanisms they  need to learn how to sell products how  to serve them there's never been a  better time  Southern glaciers wine Academy is 15  courses and the Spirit Academy is 12  classes among other offerings they've  accelerated training programs as well we  do have more information available on  our website